[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 week-end
sur tv 78 actualité et idées de sorties
pour bien terminer la semaine dans les
yvelines voici le programme de ce 11
février
la visite de jean michel blanquer dans
les yvelines le ministre de l'éducation
nationale s'est rendue au campus de
versailles ce vendredi après-midi
c'était à l'occasion du forum des
métiers et formations du patrimoine et
de l'artisanat d'excellence quelques
heures auparavant il annonçait le
nouveau protocole sanitaire dans les
écoles la performance du football-club
de versailles les yvelinois se sont
qualifiés mercredi pour les demi finales
de la coupe de france face à eux
désormais l'ogcnice clubs de ligue 1
pour décrocher la finale retour sur
cette semaine historique pour les verts
ça y est et puis comme tous les
vendredis nos idées de sorties dans les
yvelines pour samedi dimanche et dans
les jours à venir c'est dans la deuxième
partie de cette édition et c'est avec
bixente mais rien senti steban que je
suis très heureux de retrouver après
deux semaines d'absence et ce à la
dernière rigoriste et ce à deux semaines
a recensé retour en pleine forme on a de
découvrir la carte que vous nous avez
concocté pour aujourd'hui quel est le
menu michel téléphone se met rapidement
sait on par septième art est aussi
forcément la saint valentin la fête des
amoureux car c'est lundi et c'est tout à
leur bien sûr dont le sais tu ce week
end
l'actualité d'abord avec le nouveau
protocole sanitaire dans les écoles il a
été annoncé ce matin ce vendredi matin
par le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer air des mesures qui
entreront en vigueur à la rentrée des
vacances d'hiver principales mesures à
retenir la fin du masque obligatoire en
extérieur dans les cours de récréation
des écoles primaires en intérieur le
port du masque reste obligatoire sauf
pour la pratique d'activités physiques
et sportives à l'exception tout de même
des sports de contact autre point
retenir un seul autotests dorénavant à
pratiquer pour les élèves qui à
contacter au bout de deux jours contre
trois jusqu'à présent la fin des
attestations sur l'honneur après le
premier autotests enfin
l'assouplissement des règles de brassage
à la cantine les enfants seront
regroupés désormais par niveau et non
plus par classe au 10 février pour
précisions 297 classes étaient fermés
dans les yvelines pour cause de cofidis
quelques heures après ces annonces ce
jean michel blanquer air s'est rendu à
versailles à l'occasion du forum des
métiers formations du patrimoine et de
l'artisanat d'excellence c'était cet
après midi ce vendredi après midi et sur
place mélanie poké et patrick jacques de
dixmude préserver les savoir faire à la
française
revitaliser les vocations autour des
filières du patrimoine et de l'artisanat
projet débuté il y a deux ans le campus
versailles accueille ses premiers élèves
depuis le 13 octobre dernier aujourd'hui
de diplômes universitaires ont été mis
en place depuis ce jeudi 10 février et
jusqu'au samedi 12 février le site
organise un forum à destination de ceux
qui souhaitent découvrir les métiers
auxquels ils forment un temps des
changes auxquels est venu assister et
jean michel blanquer le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a rencontré
artisans représentant des formations et
les élèves à l'actualité à venir c'est
cette grande journée de sensibilisation
au handicap elle se déroule ce samedi au
centre commercial westfield vélizy 2 en
collaboration avec plusieurs
associations partenaires au programme
échanges ateliers et mise en situation
et notamment des parcours en fauteuil
roulant ou l'expérience d'un café dans
le noir le rendez-vous sera rythmée
également de plusieurs performances
artistiques pour illustrer le thème de
l'inclusion c'est de 11h à 18h c'est la
fin de la semaine et avant d'aborder la
nouvelle que faut-il retenir de
l'actualité des derniers jours dans les
îles mélanie poquet vous résume le tout
en 70 secondes
[Musique]
des travaux d'envergure le samedi 5
février le travel a tort de la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines a été installé
sur les quais une nouvelle étape dans la
modernisation du site qui a que quelques
70 mille voyageurs par jour
un projet contesté à magnanville la
mobilisation se poursuit contre le
projet de prison l'établissement devrait
être de 700 places et voir le jour à
l'horizon 2027 une ville derrière son
équipe commerce et habitants étaient
présents pour soutenir le fc versailles
lors de son quart de finale face à
bergerac la cité royale s'est enflammé
après la qualification en demi finale de
coupe de france un jeu événement un
meilleur jeu de l'année c'est peut-être
le titre que décrochera appui city le 24
février prochain édité par l'entreprise
versaillaise cocktail games le jeu de
cartes le raf a sa carte à ventura et
seven wonders architectes ancien
président de tv 60,18 gerald de favier a
également oeuvré pendant 22 ans en tant
qu'adjoint au maire d'elancourt
vice-président de 50 ans ni vis ni
laisse derrière lui de multiples
réalisations il s'était retiré de la vie
politique en 2018 pour s'occuper de sa
famille
gerald de favier vient de nous quitter à
81 ans
[Musique]
le retour anticipé de bixente mais rien
senti steban en plateau avant de nous
donner envie de sortir dans les yvelines
bixente vous rentrer en jeu pour nous
parler d'une semaine historique celle
passée par le football-club de
versailles 78 car c'est l'information de
cette semaine les versaillais sont
qualifiés pour la demi finale de la
coupe de france en effet grégory il
avait rendez vous avec l'histoire
c'était une semaine on ne peut plus
chargés pour les joueurs amateurs de
versailles cette semaine qu'on a suivi
quasiment dans son intégralité ici à atv
78 et ça a commencé lundi avec le
premier entraînement de la semaine ou
plutôt un décrassage lundi c'était
tennis ballon petit taureau rencontre
avec les médias écoutez le jeune
défenseur de 22 ans est capitaine maël
durant de jeu vignes et avec qui j'ai pu
échanger un petit peu
voilà j'en récupère du match précédent
parce que c'est un chêne vide sans ce
moment et dès demain on va se mettre à
100% dans la cuc on va se concentrer on
va travailler dessus et après à partir
là bas donc on va commencer à vraiment
être dedans donc comme l'a dit le jeune
défenseur de la cité royale mardi les
joueurs ont commencé à se plonger dans
la rencontre entraînement tactique
préparation mentale et physique
et puis arrive le mercredi lever aux
aurores pour les joueurs en vue du
déplacement à périgueux et lever aux
aurores pour vous aussi grégory qui est
parti avec michael et me d'euros suivre
les supporters tout au long de la
journée vous nous avez retransmis via
les réseaux sociaux l'ambiance du quart
versailles et les supporters ont donné
de la voix regardez l'ambiance allait
pas terrible ambiance
[Applaudissements]
voilà
ouais
oui ça
et ouais toi
chico et les chants qui témoigne de
l'impatience d'arriver à l'instant
fatidique la rencontre et cette fameuse
demi finale coup d'envoi à 18h30 au
stade francis rongiéras de périgueux le
scénario de la rencontre je crois qu'on
en a tous entendu parler ces derniers
jours versailles ouvre le score en début
de match vers la quinzième minute sous
les encouragements de la centaine de
versailles ayant fait le déplacement
jusque dans le sud mais aussi des 1006
n'est plus sur la place du marché vers
16 ou un écran géant avait été posée
pour suivre le match mais versailles se
fait égaliser à la dernière minute et là
c'est la stupeur séance de tirs au but
avec un ascendant psychologique pour
bergerac grégory vous qui étiez au stade
comment vous l'avez senti honnêtement
est nickel on était plutôt pessimiste
après l'égalisation de bergerac on s'est
dit que l'ascendant psychologique
justement était passé du côté de
bergerac et la séance de tirs au but
nous a fait mentir heureusement pour les
versaillais exactement les joueurs
versailles et ont su garder la tête
haute ils ont inscrit leurs cinq
penaltys contrairement à leurs
adversaires qui en manque un
qualification en demi finale de coupe de
france et libération
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah
c'est une grande fierté d'avoir un club
qui fait un tel exploit surtout c'est
notre ville c'est versailles
là on est tous là les versaillais on est
tous ensemble et on va essayer de vote
soit niçois rémy sent que c'est
marseille ensuite leur tour grégory vous
êtes rentré avec les supporters la nuit
arrive et 4h 5h du matin environ les
jolies courbes exactement owen daniels
courte mais le lendemain édition
spéciale les joueurs eux sont rentrés
également le lendemain avait après une
nuit courte également il a diarra souba
le buteur nous l'a confié hier il était
l'invité de votre édition spéciale
édition spéciale à revoir d'ailleurs
pour tous ceux qui n'ont pas encore
regardé avec un long format de votre
aventure avec michael et demi d'euros je
fais un peu de pub un jour vous avez
raison et dernière étape hier le retour
des joueurs au stade mont boron la
communion avec les supporters présents
pour les accueillir c'est super sympa
c'est super sympa de voir qu'on est
soutenue suivie et appréciée par par
notre ville et de rentrer comme ça en
vainqueur c'est agréable ça fait plaisir
ça fait plaisir donc on voit qu'on a
fait plaisir aux gens voilà que qu'on
ait soutenu
[Applaudissements]
est alors grande fête encore qui va se
poursuivre puisque en demi finale
l'adversaire c'est un club de ligue 1
c'est nice c'est ça le match se jouera
le 2 mars prochain à 21h et ça devrait
être en région parisienne une bonne
nouvelle trois stades sont pressentis
pour accueillir la rencontre
le favori c'est le stade charléty avec
ses vingt mille places mais il ya plus
gros et c'est ce que préfère d'ailleurs
les supporters et les joueurs quand on
leur pose la question c'est le parc des
princes l'enceinte du paris saint
germain avec ses 41 sièges et plus
encore imaginer le stade de france
l'immense enceinte de 80000 spectateurs
difficile à remplir mais pourquoi pas en
finale en cas de nouvel exploit c'est ça
on va attendre le stade de france pour
la finale ça veut dire que ça voudrait
dire que les versaillais sont en finale
alors attention à ne pas se relâcher
c'est vrai que cette demi finale qui va
arriver le 2 mars mais il ya d'autres
échéances avant pour le football club de
versailles oui l'objectif premier du
club ça reste le championnat de
nationale 2 qu'il domine pour le moment
et pour remporter le championnat il
faudra une victoire dans le derby
yvelinois c'est ce samedi face à poissy
on suivra tout ça bien sûr avec
attention les événements des prochaines
semaines merci t on vous retrouve dans
un instant pour vos idées de sorties
mais avant votre lure votre rubrique
légal check-in pour vérifier ce que
disent les acteurs de l'actualité
raphaël mata duvignau du collectif des
surligneurs et décrypte aujourd'hui est
des phrases prononcées par nicolas
dupont aignan et regardez c'est notre
rubrique
nourrir répétons depuis longtemps les
mêmes principes élémentaires du respect
des obligations internationales de la
france pour preuve dernièrement nicolas
dupont aignan entend refuser
l'application de la jurisprudence de la
cour de justice de l'union européenne et
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme ces deux juridictions rappelons
le contrôler la bonne application
respectivement des traité sur l'union
européenne et de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme et en
cherchant à lutter contre ces décisions
juridictionnelles le député appelle
purement et simplement à violer les
engagements internationaux de la france
en effet la france est engagée
souverainement et librement à les
respecter et n'a donc actuellement pas
d'autre choix que de se soumettre aux
décisions rendues par les juridictions
européennes sous peine d'engager sa
responsabilité et de se voir infliger
les sanctions notamment financières pour
atteindre son objectif
nicolas dupont aignan disposons de deux
solutions juridiquement acceptable mais
très improbable à mettre en oeuvre
premièrement renégocier les traités afin
d'autoriser expressément le non respect
des décisions des deux courts vidant
ainsi les textes repères d'une partie
importante de leur substance solution
possible juridiquement mais
politiquement très improbable dans la
mesure où pour réviser les traités
européens l'unanimité des états parties
c'est-à-dire 26 points européenne et 47
pour le conseil de l'europe est requise
il risque donc une différence notoire
entre théorie et pratique
deuxièmement et de manière plus radicale
quitter l'union européenne et le conseil
de l'europe en droit c'est possible mais
très compliqué avec des conséquences
insoupçonnables l'exemple anglais le
démontre une fois ces frais exit
entériné la france devra alors négocier
avec chaque pays européens et avec ses
partenaires extra européens les bases de
nouvelles relations commerciales
fiscales économiques judici r ou encore
diplomatique et il n'est d'ailleurs pas
certain que la france sorte gagnante de
ces nouvelles négociations d'autres
personnalités politiques ont l'encan
longuement soutenu ces mêmes positions
pour aujourd'hui les abandonner la
réalité est dure mais c'est la réalité
et surligneurs continueront à rabâcher
inlassablement les règles du
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes
allez c'est l'heure de sortir dans les
yvelines dans ce set week-end
et votre invité bixente il nous a
rejoint en plateau il vient parler
cinéma on le connaît bien atv 78 il
était passé en tant que stagiaire dans
la rédaction oui bonjour thomas salazar
vous avez 20 ans vous êtes le
réalisateur du film mon doudou c'est un
film que vous avez réalisé avec
l'association jolie prod il a été tourné
l'été dernier et l'avant première c'est
demain samedi 12 février à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ça fait quoi
de voir un projet de l'ong greenpeace a
fait six ans que vous le travail est
définitivement aboutir c'est ça
exactement en fait j'avais lu il est le
court métrage est librement adapté
inspiré par don de la nouvelle dino de
dino buzzati ce pauvre petit garçon
j'avais lu quand j'étais en troisième
donc voilà donc on est quand même sur un
laps de temps assez long dit
depuis j'ai écrit d'autres choses et
l'association jolie prod qu'elle fût
adhérents m'a proposé est ce que tu veux
réaliser un court métrage j'ai dit ouais
complètement et j'ai ouvert mon dossier
sur mon ordinateur avec il y en a six ou
sept dedans comme qui sont finis deux
scénarios d'autres qui viennent juste de
commencer et je dis ah c'est pas mal ça
pour pour commencer ça peut être pas mal
quand je verrai ouvert j'ai fait à oui
j'étais en troisième et effectivement
quand je les prix du coup j'ai dû
composer il ya deux ans c'est ça
exactement il ya deux ans on devait le
tourner
l'an 2020 mais on a eu une crise
sanitaire quasiment entendue par des on
a dû
reporter d'un an après et le film du
coup se veut être une aventure humaine
avec les acteurs c'est des enfants la
plupart notamment est ce que vous pouvez
me donner un petit pitch rapidement un
petit pitch alors c'est l'histoire d'un
petit garçon qui va au parc avec sa mère
et il ya un groupe d'enfants d'habitude
ce groupe d'enfants il est très hostile
avec ce petit garçon mais cette fois ci
ils décident de bien vouloir l'inclure
dans le jeu voilà un film d'ailleurs
tourné en territoire rambolitains vous
propose d'en regarder un petit extrait
[Musique]
honteux déjà dit non en plus elle même
pas d'armes
mais si on regarde les installer
[Musique]
donc c'est un film déjà sélectionné dans
plusieurs festivals notamment le marché
du film à clermont-ferrand où le lift
off global festival en angleterre quand
on est jeune réalisateur comme ça ça
fait quoi de d'avoir ce film justement
sélectionné dans des festivals et une
projection en avant-première au cinéma
ah bah c'est assez incroyable les
festivals déjà c'est très fort aux
journées ainsi expliqué de jolis prod
qui s'est mis à rechercher du festival
voit donc le signe d'un juste de
commencer sa carrière on a fait deux il
a été finalisé la fin décembre début
janvier donc en moi déjà faire de
festival c'est quand même pas mal et
pour l'avant-première ben voilà on
remercie la deux le cratère et toute la
communauté de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
qui nous permet de faire ça vraiment
c'est vraiment une occasion en or et ça
va être jédir une belle soirée mais
c'est passé l'après-midi
s'est passé le tournage justement
puisque vous êtes dans la peau du
réalisateur maintenant et il fallait le
gérer par exemple les enfants comment ça
s'est passé et bah déjà c'est en amont
du tournage on a cassé des enfants sur
sur la commune dr murray qui la plupart
font partie de la commune dernier voilà
la commune très gentiment nous à nous a
donné des locaux nous a traités de
locaux donner des lieux de tournage et
où on a tourné sur trois jours
en extérieur la météo voilà n'a pas été
forcément clémente avec nous
et puis oui voilà que les enfants c'est
vraiment un exercice qui est compliqué
de base en fait c'est à dire que diriger
les acteurs c'est compliqué mais diriger
des enfants c'est encore plus compliqué
voilà il fallait il fallait bien leur
faire comprendre
tout ce qu'on voulait en même temps que
ça fasse un petit peu naturelle mais
voilà il ya toute l'équipe qui a
travaillé avec moi de jolis prône
notamment pour la direction des acteurs
il y avait clairement dié et julien
denervaud de jolis prod qui en plus car
pierre soubie a fait des études de
théâtre c'est pour ça que qu'elle a été
voilà quel était apte à amédée dessus et
au final ça s'est bien passé et le rôle
de réalisateur il vous plaît parce que
vous aviez déjà occupé différents rôles
dans la réalisation de films vous aviez
participé à d'autres courts-métrages est
ce que c'est ça un rôle qui vous a plu
qui vous donne envie de recommencer bien
sûr ça roule qui maquille ma chique plus
mais depuis le début depuis l'origine je
veux faire ça deux filles et des fils
début donc c'est sûr que wallace mais en
tout cas ça m'a permis de me rendre
compte de plusieurs choses de la
difficulté c'est dire qu'au début c'est
un rêve et en fait quand on est dedans
s'est fait un peu plus on est en réalité
c'est ça exactement et comme un temps
fait le film le film que les 7 minutes
et 4 secondes pour être précis direct le
chronométrage le monde apprécie on a vu
du coup un bout du making of nous la
projection c'est demain à 14 heures
exactement et voilà qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter entendre au futur en fait
du film pour vous votre culture en tant
que réalisateur ou alors pour le futur
proche déjà que
y'a du monde à cette avant-première et
que ça plaise que le film plaise dire on
projette le film ensuite il ya une
session de questions réponses et après
il ya le making of du coup qu'on voit
après pour bien se rendre compte du
travail avec les enfants de ce que ça
représente ils aventure humaine aussi de
ceux de ce tournage et pour ce qu'on
peut souhaiter dans un futur plus ou
intense et souvent n'avait que 20 ans
donc c'est vrai c'est encore le temps
d'avoir une belle carrière au cinéma
c'est un bon âge c'est va de continuer
comme ça des deux monte petit à petit en
ambition et en échelon en tout cas c'est
ce qu'on vous souhaite donc merci thomas
salazar d'avoir été avec nous votre film
mon doudou sera donc projeté en avant
première demain samedi 12 février au
cinéma le cratère à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines projection à
14 heures en présence de l'équipe du
fise votre équipe merci thomas
réalisateur lourdement avoue thomas
alors à présent bixente vous nous parler
d'un autre
rendez-vous à suivre samedi soir on veut
au cabaret à cerner la ville exactement
demain soir on pourra retrouver la
comédie musicale cabaret quatre saisons
au cabaret du bout des prêts de cerner
la ville les quatre saisons de vivaldi
mais c'est aussi une pizza bien connue
bien spéciale vous vous l'avez souvent
séparés en quatre portions enfin bref à
la comédie musicale parle justement de
mario un pizzaïolo des années 60 roi de
la fête une comédie sympa à voir sous la
forme d'un dîner spectacle est à voir
d'autant plus qu'en première partie un
événement bien spécial un défilé de mode
ça paraît plutôt un problème et oui elle
s'appelle les enchanteuses et présentent
leurs collections vox des accessoires et
vêtements confectionnés à partir des
velours d oui c'est ça les velours rouge
du cinéma vox de rambouillet en fait
quand le cinéma fermé elles en ont
profité pour récupérer le grand rideau
rouge qui allaient sinon partir à la
déchetterie défilé à partir de 19h30 au
cabaret des quatre saisons de cerner la
ville un voyage au brésil à présent vous
nous fait rêver bixente le temps d'une
soirée toujours c'est ça on part du côté
des plages de copacabana à rio flavia
coelho la chanteuse aux sonorités groove
afro caribéennes hip hop et bossa nova
notamment se produira vendredi 18
février à plaisir sur la scène de la clé
des champs elle présentera son nouvel
album 10 nm on écoute l'artiste
[Musique]
musicalement c'est un disque bien sûr
qu'elle est un peu ce que j'appelle ma
patte que c'est de mélanger du verset
rythme diverses et variées jouer avec
des basses
de sonorités un peu plus aubaine tels
que la trappe le hip hop etc mais est
toujours avoir des guitares brésilienne
avoir voilà le flou ensuite niveau des
paroles c'est un disque un peu plus se
rentrer dedans parce que je voulais à
tout prix
parler de l'actualité ce qui est en
train d'arriver dans mon pays en fait
l'arrivée des ex thème
des choses qui existent depuis toujours
en fait le racisme les inégalités
le mot phobie donc j'ai écrit des
paroles qui ont été quand même difficile
à écrire et à les interpréter parce que
je parlais de mon pays
je suis né avec jalil dans les années 80
je commençais à faire la musique à l'âge
de 14 ans on est cependant une annonce
d'un casting
j'ai utilisé pas ce groupe d'espèces de
bande de des bals des champs de riz
please et c1 depuis ce groupe où je ne
passais pas une vingtaine d'autres
jusqu'à l'âge de 26 ans je décide des
plans avions et venir vivre en france
pour comme masque la voiture d'un
premier album
c'est vraiment le titre qui était le
plus difficile comment décrire car ils
décrivent est mort ce qui est la ville
de janeiro en dehors le tableau que les
gens qui connaissent le christ voilà la
mer la mer la plage etc donc c'est une
ville que j'aime indique je passais
beaucoup de temps de ma vie là-bas et
qui est malheureusement
depuis toujours
quand tu subis les violences des
inégalités diverses et variées
[Musique]
oui
celui-là
[Musique]
m
là
parmi eux
tu as dû passer
[Musique]
merci à la merveilleuse et
excellentissime celi agathe son go qui a
rencontré la chanteuse flavia coelho je
dis pas ça parce qu'elle vient de nous
rejoindre la torture
c'est bien ce qu'ont démenti à moteur
vous êtes vous venu nous parler d'amour
oui elles ont tancé lundi exactement la
saint valentin c'est dadis et lundi et
moi j'ai trois cadeaux made in china
vous proposait alors un fini le
traditionnel bouquet de fleurs et le
restaurant romantique et will gregory
bixente il va falloir être plus inventif
que j'avais pris ma famille
personnellement j'ai pas choisi cette
année est bien je vais vous proposer des
idées pour par alors plus ou moins
original mais surtout fait dans les
yvelines un geste pour nos commerçants
et iv loin qui ont vécu des durs moments
à ces temps ci alors on commence par une
jeune entreprise qui fête bientôt ses
deux ans d'existence
lb maroquinerie conçoit et fabrique des
accessoires en cuir fait main à bois
d'arcy la gérante donne des noms propres
à ces sacs qui sont souvent un très
coloré un des derniers s'appelle camille
sée 1 500 tueur qui se porte aussi en
sacoche donc homme ou femme donc là pour
le coup tout le monde pour tout le monde
peut la voir et après sinon bah j'ai le
fameux valentine qui étaient sortis
l'année passée pour la saint valentin et
après sinon c'est plein de petites
maroquineries des portes car des porte
monnaie des porte-clés il y en a
vraiment pour tous les goûts et toutes
les couleurs c'est un exemple de
couleurs assez neutre qui peut être
aussi bien féminins que masculins on est
sur du marines du bleu ciel et donc je
cours en fait
à la petite sangle ici nom qui est
réglable et comme ça on peut le mettre
aussi bien à la taille que portait en
fait on s'accroche comme un sac banane
donc ça c'était votre première idée pour
trouver le cadeau idéal mais on part à
poissy désormais vous avez repéré un
produit dont le savoir-faire date du
xviie siècle oui alors connaissez-vous
le noyer de poissy absolument pas du
tout pas du tout et bien c'est une
liqueur à base d'amandes de noyau
d'abricot qui est fabriqué dans cette
distillerie à a fois ci il y a deux
recettes une blanche et une andré
parfait pour une soirée romantique à la
maison avec un bon cocktail ça s'utilise
aussi bien en apéritif
quand digestif ça se met aussi en
cocktail et en cuisine donc il ya plein
de trucs à faire avec à offrir à une
personne qui à la personne et pour le
coup c'est bientôt la saint valentin
qui nous est cher et qui pourra être
utilisé autant dans les cocktails
d'amoureux que dans les gâteaux
d'amoureux que voilà où ou soit pour se
faire plaisir avec les copains par la
suite alors c'est samedi ils font un
atelier dégustation de cocktails en
partenariat avec les vins de hbo qui se
marie très bien avec le noyau de toi si
pareil pour ceux qui veulent fêter la
servante en avance par exemple et une
dernière idée de cadeau c'est à dire
alors plus classique à cette fois ci
pour les gourmands des chocolats basée à
meaux le lait chocolat cola présente une
gamme qui peut convenir pour la saint
valentin elle s'appelle la vie en rose
vous pouvez trouver des coeurs garnier
d'assortiment ou encore des roses et si
vous voulez que cela soit plus personnel
la chocolaterie propose des plaques
personnalisées ou des objets tout
chocolat sur mesure voilà tourné vers
moi que vous avez des gourmands
le thunder est d'ailleurs grégory qu'est
ce que vous allez offrir votre valentine
je vais pas le dire ici à regarder
l'émission dont elle n'aurait plus la
surprise ok allez on laisse la surprise
et vous michel témoin je peux donner un
petit indice j'aime bien les références
tout ça donc je vais peut-être j'ai vu
pour un truc bons rapports avec une
petite série qu'on a un bon ok elle a
souffert merci c'est bien du jour c'est
à dire il est made in yvelines et on
termine bixente avec un agenda une avant
première d'un documentaire fiction c'est
ça il s'appelle way versailles à ce sera
le film d'ouverture de fine 2022 le
festival international de films sur la
musique l'avant première en présence de
l'équipe du film sera jeudi prochain à
paris salle de la gaîté lyrique à 19h45
le film raconte l'histoire du berceau de
la french touch des artistes comme maire
etienne de crécy un euro bottini ou même
phoenix écouter marc collin une des
figures de cette french tout et
réalisateur du film
j'ai eu un choc je suis un jour aller
dans mon disquaire préféré à seattle aux
états unis j'ai vu une spéciale french
touch et j'ai quand je vois quand j'ai
pris des disques j'ai vu sur les
pochettes tous les noms boudemaghe de
mes copains de mes copains d'école de
classe etc donc je j'ai vraiment eu un
choc on est inquiet ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi est ce qu'on fait c'est
finalement tout pourrait si vous avez
tous fini par pas réussir dans la
musique j'ai voulu raconter en fait
cette histoire j'ai c'est une troisième
pour la route la french touch oui c'est
mieux je n'ai pas noté voilà que le
président une projection est prévue
prochainement du côté de versailles
merci bixente pour ses idées pour nous
avoir fait un petit peu rigoler sur sur
la fin de ce cette ut week-end mais mon
accent anglais nan mais je vais pas me
je vais pas me vanter j'ai pas le très
très bon accent anglais non plus voilà
c'est la faute se situe ce week-end
merci bixente merci pour toutes ces
idées de sorties merci également à vous
de nous avoir suivi l'information locale
qui revient dès lundi en direct avec le
journal de la rédaction à 18h et d'ici
là passez un excellent week-end sur tv
[Musique]